uber is releasing new information about
uber air an ambitious plan to launch a
fleet of autonomous flying taxis in two
years we got the first look at the
design models that will be on display at
today's uber elevate summit in Los
Angeles but launching an air taxi
service could be risky for a company
already facing problems with its fleet
on the ground bianna golodryga
interviewed the CEO of uber and then
flew back overnight on a plane to be
with us this morning
uber says they're willing to take that
risk John good morning we've all been
there stuck in bumper-to-bumper traffic
just wishing that we could fly over the
congestion well now uber says that dream
can turn into reality with uber air
imagine flying instead of driving to
your destination at up to 200 miles an
hour just by using an app on your phone
we think cities are going to go vertical
in terms of transportation and we want
to make that a reality so uber CEO Derek
owes Russia he says this model of an air
taxi shows the company's vision for the
future of Transportation it's a world
where passengers request an uber air on
their phone and then head to these
rooftops Sky ports where the aircraft
take off we want to create the network
around those vehicles so that regular
people can take these taxis in the air
for longer distances when they want to
avoid traffic at affordable prices it's
going to be really really community
friendly and chef Holden is uber chief
product officer so it's using these
stacked what they call stacked rotors to
create vertical lifts so the thing lifts
up kind of like a helicopter but then
when it gets to the right altitude it
this this rotor here kicks on and that's
a that's it actually creates forward
thrust and it uses the wings for lift
holden says they're still in the design
phase unlike a helicopter this aircraft
will have clusters of small propellers
and run on electricity making it quieter
more efficient and more affordable
although piloted at first the goal is
for the flying taxis to become
autonomous but questions remain about
how they will guarantee safety uber also
says for the program to become
profitable it will need to move beyond a
niche market one of the
key tenants of this technology is for us
to have four riders in each vehicle so
that you essentially the cost per ride
goes down the combination of mass market
and sharing which is really what Huber
is all about can bring this to the
masses can make it affordable for normal
people Kohl's Raja he took over a
company in crisis when he replaced
Travis kalanick as CEO in August you're
an 8 year old company still not
profitable lost four and a half billion
dollars last year why be so ambitious
now ambition is what has created this
company from the very beginning part of
what made this company great is that we
take big bold bets that's part of the
norms and the culture of this company
and this is another big bold bet that we
think ultimately is something that the
cities of the future are going to need
while kasra shahi is focused on the
future the company is still navigating a
troubled past including a March accident
involving a self-driving Ober with the
safety driver behind the wheel that
killed a pedestrian the CEO says the
software that decides how the vehicle
reacts to objects on the road may have
played a role in that crash but the
company is waiting on the results of an
NTSB investigation
what I'm doing is a top-to-bottom audits
of our procedures training software
hardware what our practices are so you
can definitively say that you're not
shutting down your autonomous unit yes I
can different anybody Tyler we're not
shutting it down we want to get back on
the road but we want to be safe when we
get back on the road the company is also
working to rehabilitate its image a
bombshell blog post last year detailing
a corporate culture of sexual harassment
was followed by numerous lawsuits and an
internal investigation that led to Cal
annex resignation how long do you give
yourself as a leader to make sure that
change is implemented for the better if
it's not changed right now then I failed
I will tell you that the company took
upon itself to change the change didn't
start with me what happened in the past
was deeply unpleasant and and wrong but
the company from the bottoms up
standpoint started changing and I think
it continues apace how important is it
for you to have female employee
to feel safe and proud to work at this
company it's game over if we don't we
want everyone at uber to feel safe and
if we fail at that we will fail at a
company but we don't intend to Kohl's
Rochelle he says he's concentrating not
just on correcting the company's past
missteps but on making the necessary
strides to ensure the company's future
growth including the launch of uber air
you know you've got to set aggressive
goals in order to push teams and people
to make those goals
uber plans to have uber air flight
demonstrations as early as 2020 the
company is also partnered with NASA to
develop technology to control air
traffic and prevent crashes the first
two were air cities will be Dallas and
Los Angeles and about the company's
bottom line coach o shahe said look we
are profitable in some cities and we're
choosing to use that money to invest in
technology we'll see what what investors
ultimately say in the long run sorry mr.
kosher hot Sailor sake yes Dara he's
making it very clear that there's a new
sheriff in town and he's really setting
a different mission and a different face
for the company yeah seemingly in a very
good powerful strong way and he felt
very open to talk to us about it all boy
he has a lot of balls in the air I mean
he's a lot going on to put this big new
thing he wants to be the Amazon of
Transportation as what he said all right
tonight you say that beyond and I were
on the same red-eye flight I got off
feeling like a dishrag it but it
quartered at 6:00 we're at JFK and the
flight attendant said you guys are never
gonna make it and we both made now you
look fresh as a daisy you brought down
the average we've got two hours on this
at this table
[Laughter]